arizona deploying the national guard to
help combat the state's spiraling crisis
at our southern border the mayor of yuma
also declaring a local emergency as
thousands of migrants have flooded the
city within just the last five days and
he joins us now with the latest on the
situation on the ground
mayor of yuma douglas nichols mayor um
it's so great to have you on the show
first of all merry christmas and welcome
i have many friends in yuma and they
have been telling me for a long time
that things were going very badly but it
seems like um there's a new low um in
the crisis so tell me what's happening
and and how your community is dealing
with it
well we're currently in some
unprecedented waters here um
up to this point this last year we had a
very contained um situation border
patrol and ice were able to work with
some non-profits
and bring people through the system
without really a whole lot of impact to
the community well last weekend we had
those six thousand people came um over
the four day period which overwhelmed
the border patrol system and so people
were waiting at the border for border
patrol to pick them up for almost a day
day and a half and so they just started
walking
through town and
doing what they they need to do take
care of humanitarian issues water food
shelter uh on their way to try to find
the border patrol station so that really
caused the community a little bit of
chaos but really what the purpose of the
of the declaration is to make sure we're
not the epicenter of a humanitarian
crisis that could be quickly developing
mr mayor based on your calculation why
is this happening why now why this many
it's a little bit um
of a mystery but i think it's related to
the re-implementation of the remaining
mexico policy which is a bit of a
misunderstanding that policy has been
dramatically changed on its
implementation
and so when it is fully implemented this
this next week it'll only provide
room for 10 people a day out of the yuma
sector so it's not going to dramatically
change what we've got going on here
because that's about one percent of the
traffic coming through but i think it's
that panic of trying to get in the
country before that that was that
program goes back into effect
mayor you've declared the local
emergency you said to get ahead of what
could be a humanitarian crisis a
burgeoning humanitarian crisis what does
that look like in your town
well
right now we've been very fortunate
because since i've declared the numbers
have dropped and it's more manageable
for border patrol but should have they
stayed at that level
you would have had hundreds potentially
thousands of people at a time
that were looking for water looking for
food you know walking uh through our
community but not just the city itself
but the surrounding agricultural areas
and so that's
very important for us to make sure that
those things don't happen because of the
ancillary impacts impacts to our health
care system impacts to just you know the
general
humanitarian issues that arrive and you
have that many people without resources
yeah where where will they use the
restroom sanitary sanitary issues i mean
i can't imagine all of a sudden an
influx of thousands how you deal with
that that's one that's one problem and
that's a big one
yes
and this time of year while we're in the
desert it drops uh rachel might remember
this it drops really cold in the middle
of the night
and during the day it's sunny and great
but in the middle of night it's below
freezing and we're talking little kids
we're talking elderly people we're
talking people that are at risk and we
don't want to see that happen either
yeah well your call for help um
hopefully we'll be heard you have two
democrat senators who now say they want
something to be done about it so maybe
maybe something will be done maybe not
we'll see thank you mayor absolutely mr
mayor thank you so much and